ever since Aristotle we've been told
that we have five senses but it's now
thought we could have around 20 or more
for example the sense that tells you
you're feeling hot or cold the sense
that tells you you're out of breath and
the sense of balance you don't
consciously experience the raw
information all these senses generate
because the brain is constantly engaged
in the act of perception the analysis
synthesis and interpretation of all that
data in certain situations though this
type of processing results in mistakes
like this you're probably seeing two
different colors here but in fact
there's only one
we very often see faces because we're
hardwired to tune into them
our ability to navigate the world is
entirely dependent on the complex
mechanisms which interpret all the noise
our senses make and give it meaning as
the famous neurologist Oliver Sacks put
it every Act of perception is to some
degree an Act of Creation